while audiences get to go back to the
future again since the moment production
wrapped on the third film in the Back to
the Future trilogy director Robert
Zemeckis and writer Bob Gale have had to
deal with fans asking if a fourth film
whatever happened here's their answer
for a while Doc Brown actor Christopher
Lloyd sounded completely up for reprise
in his role and it fourth Back to the
Future
he mentioned during Niagara Falls Comic
Con in June 2019 that he felt a possible
sequel would work best if it did two
things addressed something important in
our current culture and managed to
maintain the feeling of the first three
films in the franchise I think somehow
it needs to kind of convey a message
about something that's important to
everyone universally like climate change
and keep the feeling of one two and
three that's a tricky tricky deal
because you don't want to do another one
at disappoint so I don't know I'd be
happy to for myself but we'll see he
also praised Marty McFly actor Michael J
Fox and noted that Fox's battle with
Parkinson's disease hadn't dampened its
spirits however Lloyd's hopeful tone
changed by the end of 2019 in December
of that year at German Comic Con
Dortmund the actor said definitively
that a fourth Back to the Future movie
isn't happening though he still shared
an idea he had for another visit to the
Back to the Future franchise a crossover
with the Adult Swim animated series Rick
and Morty which originally evolved from
an animated Back to the Future parody
entitled the real animated adventures of
doc and Marty Lloyd said I think it's
fabulous I've watched Rick and Morty I
love the humor in it I love the
characters I've had a fantasy that they
could make another back to the future
it's not happening but if it did Back to
the Future 4 collides with Rick and
Morty can't kiss you guys aren't ready
for that yet but your kids are gonna
love it well Lloyd remained enthusiastic
about a possible Back to the Future poor
throughout the years director Zemeckis
has been firmed from the beginning about
such a project never happening according
to The Hollywood Reporter Folsom Equis
and Bob Gale have it written in their
original contracts with Universal
Pictures and Steven Spielberg's Amblin
entertainment that the two would have
final say on any future Back to the
Future films for as long as they're both
living what Zemeckis and Gale say goes
and Zemeckis has made it clear that
another Back to the Future isn't going
to become a reality he told The
Telegraph in 2015 when
asked if he would ever sign over the
rights for another Back to the Future
movie or remake I mean to me that's
outrageous especially since it's a good
movie
it's like saying let's remake Citizen
Kane who are we going to get to play
Kane what folly
what insanity is that why would anyone
do that speaking with Italian outlet bad
taste in July 2018 Zemeckis reiterated
his position in no uncertain terms there
will never be in the most absolute way a
back to the future for there will be no
more back to the future several months
later the filmmaker sat down for a
conversation with Yahoo movies UK during
which the interviewer asked if he was
still against making a fourth back to
the future Jamaica's replied quote oh
god yes they also asked some mecca's for
his opinion about Back to the Future
topping a poll of films that audiences
want additional installments up he
shared it confirms what we all know but
what I think the fans are really saying
is that we really like this movie and if
it were possible I'd like more of it but
they understand that it can't be done
Zemeckis also noted that Michael J Fox
quote is not in the best shape with his
Parkinson's and it wouldn't be right to
make a movie with or without him
Zemeckis continued to say the idea of
making another Back to the Future movie
without Michael J Fox you know that's
like saying I'm going to cook you a
steak dinner and I'm going to hold the
beat you can't do that
the most recent development regarding a
possible Back to the Future 4 came from
Gail in February 2020 and it's just this
bleak as the mecca says past remarks
Gail told the BBC we already made a lot
of money you know you don't sell your
kids into prostitution it was the wrong
thing to do we put the end at the end of
part 3 plus Michael J Fox isn't in the
shape to do a movie and nobody wants to
see Marty McFly having Parkinson's
disease and nobody wants to see another
actor playing Marty McFly if it's
supposed to be a continuation Gail
continued explaining that he and
Zemeckis would never want to tarnish the
legacy of the Back to the Future
franchise or ruin anyone's memory of it
by making another film in order to
create more Back to the Future content
without any negative consequences Gale
scripted a Back to the Future musical
instead studios have gone back to the
well on some of their franchise
properties too many times and the
audiences are disappointed and say oh my
god they ruined my childhood we don't
want to ruin anyone's childhood and
doing a musical is the perfect way to
give the public more back to the future
without messing up what is gone before
audiences will just have to be happy
with the numerous non film Back to the
Future related projects that have come
out in the years since the last film's
release there's been a Back to the
Future the ride a Back to the Future
cartoon series Back to the Future the
game and a true comic-book sequel series
co-written by Gael and might just be
plenty without having to go back to the
future again for another sequel check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you